[Music]
what are we doing
jacob blake's father asked that same
question after learning that his son was
shot seven times in the back
after learning that kenosha police tried
to murder his son
after learning that his grandkids
watched it all happen in the back seat
like he didn't matter what are we doing
hey training officers the killers and
shooting protesters with these rebel
bullies they regular people i know that
they feel like these scars too deep they
heal us what happened to colgan nobody
remember
what are we doing can anyone answer that
it's exhausting being black
we are scared as black people because
this isn't the first time a black person
has asked that
it's not now when maya moore wants to
know george hill wants to know
jaylen brown wants to know what the hell
are we doing
all you hear is donald trump and all of
them talking about fear
we're the ones getting killed coven 19
ain't the only pandemic that can shut
down the nba nba teams refusing to play
their scheduled games
in protest of racial injustice we're not
responsive to perception
when we're trying to change reality i
think it's best for me
to support the players and just not be
here tonight
so what are we doing we're protesting to
be heard don't listen to these people
telling you don't do anything because
it's not going to end right away
embrace it and be the change because you
are the change
we going to back i gotta toast it we're
voting for change in november we're
fighting against voter suppression
we're not being silent we're demanding
an answer wearing a t-shirt is not
enough we need to be able to create
those avenues for people you got to be
better you got to do better you got to
walk better
let's use our love and our intelligence
to show the rest of the world how humans
are supposed to treat each other no
matter your race to me we all
are black and as each game in the
playoffs grows more important
we can't ever forget what's most
important
so what are you doing